so here we have a sample of titanium
wire titanium is a really quite
fantastic metal it's very very
lightweight and very very strong it's
used in construction materials very low
concentrations and as additives for
alloys titanium is a very interesting
element and it's interesting because
it's very abundant on the planet it's
not the most eminent metal but it's
still pretty abundant this is a periodic
table where the area of each of the
elements here represents the relative
amount of this material that is found on
the earth as you can see there's a lot
of oxygen a lot of carbon quite a lot of
boron Debbie's favorite element some
aluminium again a lot and here titanium
is quite a reasonable amount nearly as
much as potassium so it's a very common
element so we're going to open it now
will hopefully see the titanium wire
around the spindle so you can see it's a
really quite beautiful dark coloration
you can find large deposits of titanium
dioxide in various places across the
world
we've just had a visitor from South
Africa who said not far from where he
works in East London along the coast
there are large deposits of titanium
dioxide the problem is that it is really
quite hard to make titanium metal out of
the oxide because titanium atoms bond
strongly to the oxygen and it's
difficult to get them apart and get the
metal and the reason why people want to
get the metal is because it's very light
here I've got a piece of titanium and
it's great light you can see I can shake
it around in my hands without behaving
it as if it was a really heavy bar often
used as well in the construction of
aerospace all sort of capsules and
components to go into space because it's
light and strong being liked by itself
is not much use sodium is light the
great thing about titanium
is that it is light and it's strong and
also it doesn't react with water you
couldn't make a car out of sodium the
first rainstorm and boom but titanium is
light it is strong so if you're making a
vehicle out of it the vehicle isn't very
heavy so you don't need nearly as much
fuel than if you're making the vehicle
out of steel usually people make the
vehicle out of aluminium which is
lighter than steel but is not nearly as
strong and the great thing about
titanium is its fantastically strong
once you get the metal so the problem
getting the metal is from titanium
dioxide titanium dioxide is a white
powder in fact you can see it round you
if you look around the room you're in
almost certainly the walls are white
with titanium dioxide it's a very cheap
white pigment normally what happens in
the process for making titanium metal is
that first of all it is converted to
titanium tetrachloride ticl4 and if you
just leave it as titanium tetrachloride
in the air it will react with the air
with water in the air and go back to
titanium dioxide you haven't achieved
anything in fact one of my colleagues
rich born so Brady earlier what happens
with this reaction I've never seen it
but I had to stay in my office and work
however you can take titanium
tetrachloride and convert it to the
metal and once you've got the metal it's
pretty unreactive provided that you keep
it cold if you put titanium in at high
temperatures in oxygen it will burn so
there are some processes where you would
like to use the strength of titanium but
because there's oxygen there it's not
safe but cars and most aeroplanes don't
get hot enough for
or the burdening in oxygen to be a
problem so it is a fantastic material
and if we could solve the problem of how
to make titanium metal cheaply in terms
of the energy needed to convert the
oxide into the metal then we could have
cars that were far more fuel efficient
and cheaper to run so it's a really good
goal titanium is used at the moment in
applications where strength and
lightness is more important than cost if
you're building fighter aircraft where
of course cost is important you but you
need it to be pretty light or you can
can't get to the speeds that you need to
shoot down the enemy and so on then they
will use titanium alloys if there's a
best you often use titanium for very
high pressure applications when chemists
want to do experiments at high pressure
they will often use titanium because
again it is very light and again strong
it is also has a great advantage that
it's non-magnetic and when you want to
for example do experiments in a high
magnetic field when you need something
strong you can't use steel because your
apparatus will be pulled away by the
magnet and nothing will work so titanium
has a very special applications which
can be very useful but they could be so
much more useful if we could apply it
more widely it's used where you really
need strength and where money is not
terribly important is in hip implants in
your hip you want to have something
that's very strong and very light each
time you move your leg you don't want to
be moving a cannonball something really
heavy but you want it to be really
strong and so again very often the hip
implants will be made out of titanium
the piece that goes into your leg is
made of
and ends in a ball and the part that
goes into a pelvis is often made of
polythene plastic so that you get the
ball and socket effect well one of the
most interesting applications of
titanium is as a catalyst for making
polythene polyethylene the material that
is used particularly for plastic buckets
and other plastic objects and ethylene
was first polymerized turned into
plastic some people call it ethene run
ethylene was turned in plastic before
the Second World War
with a very high pressure reaction that
produced a material that was rather soft
you couldn't for example used for making
buckets and then in the 1950s a German
chemist called Ziegler he discovered
partly also working with Natalia and
chemical matter that if you take a
titanium compound and an aluminium
compound together this was a really good
catalyst and by really good I mean one
gram of this catalyst could produce a
ton of plastic so that because titanium
is relatively cheap it means you don't
even have to get the catalyst out of the
plastic because there's so little of it
in the plastic you can just afford to
sell it in your plastic bucket without
losing much money does that mean there's
probably a little bit of titanium in my
plastic bucket at home yes and there's
probably more to taint in from the fact
that you cleaned your paintbrush when
you were painting your kitchen or
bedroom with white paint
so this to tell you